The first thing I need to do is go to the Site Map website, as we see.
Web Dash does not appear to be the
site. This site will appear. I will start typing the
site I want to create. For example, if this site exists and I run Get Free  There are
options below that we understand. We will start
learning about them, and we can leave them as they are, and we will create a
free XML sitemap. It will start working in the
body and create pages, and start counting all the pages
that can be created. After that, it will start loading in
another site. There is also an XML sitemap that we can
write as well.  The name of the website here is the people of Port
Said, and we write, for example, give me your Frequency
every day, and I start it, and it will start
downloading and viewing your
maps, as we can see. It starts downloading, and here it also starts downloading, page by page, like this.
Here, it brings each page and puts them all in a phrase
about the file, like this file.  Oh, he will get every link
we have and put it in a file so that it will appear in
front of Google, and it will be easy after it is finished.
Our form will be as follows: It tells you to download to SetMap,
and here you will download all the files. We
will download it to SetMap, which was downloaded
for us by Saif, put it
in the disktop, and we close it.
This site and the other site are also starting to download
all of its sitemaps. It will tell me that it is
already available. I left it under the name Sitemaps,
for example, and we will download this one
as well, and download its HTML. I will
download everything that was given
to us. After I finished and downloaded all the sitemaps we
have, I will start to go.  On the Web
Master website of Google, the site, as we see it,
is the following site: Google DK Sala Web
Masters. After I open it, I must, of course,
write that I have an account on Google. If I do not have one, I will
work on Gmail, and I am afraid of the account. I will write the
first thing on my Web site, Ahl Port.  I am happy
to do this and he will start uploading it
with us to add
this website to his website. Master Tool will
tell me that you have to activate your account. He will call you on it, and he will tell you that there are
easy steps that you can do if
you are on mm.com, or in other steps,
which are the same as the second, to make sure that the website
This is yours, not someone else's. He told you that you can
create an Upload Lash TML, or you can
take a tag for a specific word and put it on your site. The
easiest thing for me is that if I create an Upload Lash TML, he will tell me to
download the HTML
Date so that it is available on  This path, which
is the people of Port Said com. Slash the file that you are
uploading. I will go to my control panel and go to
upload to each sitemap that I
downloaded, and also upload to the
HTML
file. They all work one after the other. The file belongs to
Google so that Google can verify this site.  My RR and the
second setmap will upload everything that I
had uploaded to the site. After that, I will go to
my web master tool
and say, “Confirm that this is my site.”
It will tell me exactly that. You raised the argument. You are on this path. Okay. It will start telling me what the search is about.
Your name is
the one that came to you. Okay, I will go to my website,
which is the people of Port Said here, and start doing
what I do. Add a site map to it. It said to me here, “You don’t have a site that is not there.” What should I do,
uncle? Make a site map that tells me the
link it has on the people of Port Said. Do you have
Hafez?  My sitemap is a dot
XML sitemap, for example, and I create a new sitemap and then create
another one in my sitemap.
I have another one for something like this. We uploaded it. Of course, the sitemap has
765 links, so it starts to create an extension for them
in the sitemap dot HT. Dot
We have,
of course, according to if you have Google in Arabic, it reads the
other side. We have in RR, but
about six. We can answer
the
names directly because exactly what kind of
names do we have? We take the name and put it as it is with us. What else are there other names? There are
other names,
sir. We
can use them even if they are not useful.  He will tell you that it is
not useful, so we tell him
okay, be silent, that's fine now. We have it. What's
in the sitemap? Sitemap. Saimaps. And if it does
n't work, he'll tell me there's an error or there's a
problem with this sitemap, and he admits that it's a
sitemap that loads and brought it to me exactly.  765 Links
and yours brought me 500 links. He is starting to put them
in the index. I mean, he is starting to archive them or
putting them in Google. Okay. There is also something very beautiful. What is
Google does is like statistics for my site. I
mean, I know what words
reached my site. How did people reach it? What
words did they get to me?  The evidence is everything. My website
remains available in Google Analytics. How
can I subscribe to Google? After I logged into
Google Dotsla Analytics, as we all see, I
went to
Signup. I made a signup for my account. My account tells me the name of your
site. What should I write its name?  The people of
Port and his link, what will I tell him? The people of Port
Said Dot, what kind of type? Choose the type of my site
if it is, for example, Media,
and my place is Nim from Egypt. Choose my account Nim, for example, to call it Tariq and we do JetTracking ID. He tells me that you
must agree to these conditions. I tell him that there is no
problem.
OK, he will tell me now that you must follow my
tracking ID.
How will I follow my website through the tracking
ID date? He will tell me to put this code on every
page where you want to follow the status of the people
who are going and coming. I will take this code, for example, and
go to the family.  Port Said, I want to put it
in the basic form or the basic style of a
sentence. I will go and see the existing templates or
templates and choose the template on which I am
working templates. For example, this is the template that I am working on. I will make an HTML modification and put the code of
Analytics at the end of it. For example, the template is
pure.  I put the code and its content in my
name or tracking ID and I
will
implement it. Of course, the site will not be affected by anything at all,
and there is no problem, but I can, through
this code, follow the movement of my site
perfectly, and after it finishes, it will
tell me that my site is now
added to Google.  Analytics and I can keep up with everything
new and what happens
to me. Here I am supposed to keep track of everything. Incoming
visits. What people sit on their
city page. Browser. If they enter a mobile phone. What type of mobile phone is the
company
from which I get the internet? Everything about visitors is informed in a
very detailed way, so that it will tell you the type of mobile phones.
What we are entering into, if anyone is inside the
sources' mobile phone, of course, we are entering everything into it.
Of course, the issue of marketing, as I said, Mr.
Tariq Barda, is that it is not easy. You can
imagine that it is over. You will take two or
three steps and find yourself no longer existing and famous,
and people following you. You must do new things. It is necessary,
no matter what you say.  For you or you made a search here, here, and here. You
must find new things, and you invent things that are
not there as well, in order to get more visits.
After all the steps, I came to make a sitemap and
added it to Google. Of course, the sitemap is
all here.
What will I do next? After that, I will go to the
directories.  Or many things that I collected here
in a notebook file. I will see any important page
I have
in my newspaper and start adding it to
Google and add it to Yahoo or MSN. I start searching my
site in all these sites manually,
one after the other. All of these sites add my
site to me.  Wadi Dalayel is also available. I
use Google Answers because it is also very useful and
the groups belong to me.
Thank you and I am sorry if it took me a long time. Don’t forget to
subscribe to the channel and like and share so that
everyone
can benefit.